foreign  [Music]  [Music]  yay but there's one problem there's a  human has a mustache just like you  do you think I know every human being  with a mustache wearing a magnetical  outfit with a highway or his first name  on it because I don't  Bowser is coming  together we  are going to stop that monster how look  at us we're adorable oh I got this no  problem  thank you  our big adventure begins now ah get it  out get it out get it off  there's a huge Universe out there  there's a lot of galaxies  they're all counting on us  no pressure  hahaha  [Music]  [Music]  we hold the king of the Coopers  foreign  [Applause]  do you yield  I do not  I finally found it now who's gonna stop  me  what is this place  do not touch that mushroom you'll die oh  I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine come  on Mario  Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come  [Music]  foreign  [Music]